gewonnen ist bei uns der
geschäftsführende chef des
bundeskanzleramtes verbrauchen bis heute
nachmittag konnte man noch denken lieber
gar keinen gesetz als das der ampel so
richtig verstehen dass die bürger in
anbetracht der lage nicht in der wir
sind oder sie haben sich jetzt
verständigt und sind mit dem ergebnis
zufrieden also wir sind heute auch in
der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz nochmal
deutlich weitergekommen wir haben uns
jetzt vereinbart das ist klare grenzen
gibt wenn zu viele krankenhausbetten
belegt werden dass dann noch klar ist
wann tritt eine zweige regelung dann
muss zusätzlich noch getestet werden
dann tritt das in kraft das war einfach
wahnsinnig überfällig weil wir gesehen
haben dass momentan an vielen orten
einfach viel zu spät reagiert wird weil
wir solche grenzwerte nicht hatten aber
sie haben mit einem showdown gedroht sie
haben damit gedroht dass sie dieses
gesetz nicht durch den bundesrat bringen
weil sie damit nicht einverstanden waren
und ihnen was eigentlich gefehlt hat es
gibt hier ein infektionsschutzgesetz und
alle ministerpräsidenten hätten tun
können was sie für richtig halten
die situation ist ja so dass wir
momentan die schwierigste lage in der
pandemie überhaupt haben und
gleichzeitig sagen wir die pandemische
lage von nationaler tragweite ist zu
ende das passt einfach nicht das ist
eine schwierige symbolik dass
das erinnern sie auch ungern sparen ist
damit zu zitieren ist er seit vier von
fünf leuten sind geimpft wir sind durch
die schwierigste lage durch ja schon
zwei tage später ich mit ihm gesprochen
wir haben auch den koalitionären brief
geschrieben haben gesagt wir brauchen
die maßnahmen weiter das hängt nicht an
der rechtskonstruktion aber die symbolik
muss man klar sagen der letzten drei
wochen wir brauchen keine pandemische
lage mehr und wir brauchen nur noch
auslaufende maßnahmen wir regeln das
über ein bundestag wir brauchen keine
zusammentreffen der exekutive um sowas
organisatorisches wie impfen zu
besprechen das war eine schwere hypothek
im letzten drei wochen und ich glaube
aber heute sind einen wichtigen schritt
weitergekommen
und jetzt wirklich die lage im griff
nochmal zu den ministerpräsidenten die
sich bitter beklagt haben und eben damit
gedroht haben du hinten im bundesrat
dieses gesetz scheitern zu lassen daniel
günther aus schleswig holstein kann es
überhaupt nicht verstehen
ich habe nie verstanden warum einige
kolleginnen und kollegen immer die mpk
es abgewartet haben
anstatt im eigenen land zu handeln
also man kann man kann natürlich mit
ihnen gemeinsam fragen warum haben die
ministerpräsidenten nicht getan was sie
hätten tun kann worauf haben markus
söder nordrhein-westfalen
baden-württemberg
gewartet wenn sie eigentlich wie herr
günther sagt alles in der hand hatten
also dann zu handeln wenn es wirklich
extrem brennt das ist glaube ich das
steht außer frage das was wir in der
pandemie wollen ist ein vorausschauendes
frühes handeln und dazu hat es immer
gedient in dieser pandemie wenn sich die
ministerpräsidenten die bundesregierung
unterhaken und sagen vorausschauendes
handeln heißt zum beispiel am anfang der
partie schon einschränkende maßnahmen
bei der instanz von 50 dann ist noch
keine katastrophe da aber genau darum
geht es dass wir vorsorglich handeln hat
gelände ist jeder hinsicht macht dann
handeln wir in der regel zu spät ja gut
aber es hat auch noch nicht jeder so
empfunden dass diese mpk ist immer so
verloren in waren das war dann heute
offensichtlich eine sehr lohnende katrin
göring eckardt ist bei uns nun eben
diese noch nicht gewählten ampel
regierung für die grünen frau
göring-eckardt wenn sie heute sich noch
mal erinnern an diesen 27 10
das ist jetzt drei wochen her da haben
sie gesagt die ampel funktioniert ohne
dass es sie schon gibt und
wir wollen mildere maßnahmen nicht mehr
mit diesem großen bastl besteck der
großen koalition sondern mit milderen
maßnahmen und übrigens am 19 dritter ist
das alles vorbei wie erklären sie sich
die situation heute und ihr reden damals
ich habe nicht gesagt dass es an diesem
dritten vorbei ist sondern wir haben
gesagt dass die massnahmen die wir
vorschlagen bis dahin gelten sollen dass
man sich dann wieder drüber beugen soll
das muss man auch so genau so machen wir
haben damals einen vorschlag gemacht das
weiß die ganze zeit nicht üblich damit
die mpk getagt irgendwie stunden stunden
stunden und dann haben alle gewartet was
kommt jetzt und dann gab es irgendein
ergebnis an dass ich ja so dass am
nächsten tag nicht mehr gehalten hat und
andere auch nicht und dann muss das im
bundestag nachvollzogen werden und wir
haben am 27.10 gesagt wir legen unseren
vor die machen alles anders aber es war
nicht genug ja es war nicht genug das
stimmt das wird ja sofort zu geben aber
wir haben sagt wir legen vorschlag vor
und den wollen wir diskutieren
mit expertinnen und experten also wie
man das eigentlich so macht eine
demokratie
das parlament hat getagt in der ersten
lesung dann haben wir eine anhörung
gemacht haben mit vielen vielen leuten
geredet mit praktikerinnen geredet wir
haben im parlament diskutiert mit vielen
ländervertreter übrigens auch diskutiert
und dann haben wir gesehen was passiert
das ist ein wirklich granatenmäßig
krassen anstieg gibt der infektionen und
auch natürlich die situation auf den
intensivstationen mit intensivmedizinern
musste geredet werden selbst
verständigen wie gesagt nee das reicht
nicht aus was wir damals vorgeschlagen
haben wir brauchen weitere
ministerpräsident winfried kretschmann
hätte sich gewünscht dass es eine
verlängerung dieser ep lage der ipi
lager der epidemischen lage nationaler
tragweite gibt warum stellt man in
höchster not frau göring-eckardt ist die
letzte frage jetzt hier im warmup eine
völlig neue juristische lage wenn man
die andere einfach bis zum jahresende
weiter laufen lassen könnte um das in
ruhe zu machen ja weil es nicht gereicht
hätte also dass das schild epidemische
lage da ist ja erstmal nix drin und was
wir damit erlebt haben ist ja die
situation in der wir gerade sind also
mit der epidemischen lage sind wir in
genau die situation gekommen in der wir
gerade sind und ich find sie nicht sehr
befriedigend und deswegen haben wir
gesagt wir brauchen mehr bundesweite
sehr klare maßnahmen zum beispiel
geimpft getestet oder gelesen am
arbeitsplatz das ist jetzt verbindlich
verbindlich ist wieder home office das
sind zwei maßnahmen die gab es vorher
nicht in der kombination 3g auch
natürlich in den zügen auch eine
maßnahme die gab es vorher nicht und
weitere viele maßnahmen für die länder
die auch eine viel höhere
verbindlichkeit haben und das ist der
punkt also nicht zu sagen wir machen
weiter wie bisher das keine gute idee
schon gar nicht wenn da bin ich ja bei
herrn braun die situation so schlimm ist
wie sie noch nie war vor der saison denn
wie gesagt hatte man noch einen ganz
anderen eindruck das wird hier in der
runde bestimmt noch mal besprochen
werden und diesen dieses gefühl dass da
jetzt eben so etwas wie ein plan auf dem
tisch liegt das können wir dann
vollendet nur morgen haben
und wir reden auch noch darüber an
welchen stellen sie ist denn noch
nachbessern würden giovanni di lorenzo
ist bei uns chefredakteur der zeit
geschätze autor journalist und kollege
giovanni die die in diese pandemie zu
kommen und einen ersten winter von dem
überrascht zu sein ist ein unglück wenn
man von einem zweiten winter überrascht
ist wie nennt man das dann
vielleicht am ersten mal ein großer
mangel an entschlossenheit
das ist das was mir so stark ausfällt
und auch so verwundert ja die ganze
pandemie hat ja ein paar
hartnäckige vorurteile widerlegt die wir
alle hatten von diesem land nämlich dass
es ein besonders effizientes ist wir
haben zunächst einmal dieses diesem
merkwürdigen zahlen übermittlung
schwierigkeiten gehabt wenn es um die
infektionszahlen gab dann haben wir
diese verspätungen gehabt bei den
impfungen und jetzt stolpern wir wieder
in etwas rein was angeblich eine
überraschung ist ich finde man müsste da
jetzt ein jahr zurück gucken und sagen
im november vergangenen jahres ist
irgendwas gekippt
wahrscheinlich auch das vertrauen eines
teils der bürger in die maßnahmen die
getroffen wurden da gibt es nun
verschiedene ich glaube ja da wurde dann
gibt's jetzt verschiedene deutung sun
setzte einige sagen das lag an den
theologen die sich nicht einig waren
mein eindruck war es lag auch sehr stark
da waren das die ministerpräsidenten
kein besonders guten eindruck
hinterlassen haben bei dem versuch sich
auf einheitliche maßnahmen festlegen das
gilt auch schon sehr durcheinander und
hat die leute verunsichert dazu kamen
sicherlich bei vielen auch ein
gerechtigkeitsgefühl will nämlich dass
die folgen von corona die kleinen leute
viel mehr trifft als die großen und dann
begann fatalerweise waren wir dann auch
schon in einer vor wahlkampfphase und
dann im wahlkampf wo am ende doch der
eindruck da war mit dem sommer ist fast
alles vorbei
und da die wahl ja und das ist ja auch
so knapp ausgegangen ist kann es sehr
darauf an ja nicht noch 1 2 prozent zu
verschrecken die man gebraucht hat um
vielleicht das wahlergebnis zu kriegen
dass man sie gewünscht hätte und das
alles zusammen führt jetzt in dieser
lage ist ich glaube das versteht kein
richtiger das versteht wie wenige leute
verstehen vielleicht verstehen dass
irgendwelche politprofis normalen leute
nicht ich muss aber auch sagen was ich
feststelle und ich weiß dann würde mich
sehr interessieren wie der minister
braun oder auch katrin göring eckardt
das wahrnehmen ich stelle auch fest es
gibt in weiten teilen der bevölkerung
auch einen widerstand gegen maßnahmen
die als vernünftig gelten und die
eigentliche auch beschlossen sind weite
teile muss man vielleicht auch noch mal
sagen es sind diese berühmten 20
auch mehr als es ist ebenfalls nicht der
harte kern der der querdenker sondern
ich stelle das einfach im alltag fest
also vielleicht auch gleich noch mal
reden ich würde gerne auf diese
politische einschätzung noch mal abheben
hinrichs streek virologe aus bonn hat im
juli dieses jahres hier bei uns in der
sendung gesessen und
folgendes zur kenntnis gegeben
wir sind jetzt im sommerreifen modus und
müssen uns aber über den winterreifen
modus gedanken machen also ich glaube
keiner der hier sitzt sagt die pandemie
ist vorbei
wir werden im herbst alle rechnen mit
einem anstieg der infektionszahlen das
hängt vom im fortschritt ab wie stark
das sein was und wir können uns aber
jetzt gedanken machen in planspielen
gedanken machen juli sommerreifen
winterreifen wer hat giovanni di lorenzo
das wechseln der reeder vergessen dem in
den herbstferien also ist das etwas was
sie sagen das ist er der bundeskanzlerin
anzukreiden der rücksichtnahme auf den
wahlkampf auf sie wollte nicht mit armin
laschet streiten öffentlich sie wollte
auch keinen streit mit dem
bundesgesundheitsminister also wer hat
vergessen den reifenwechsel vorzunehmen
es ist immer eine ganz große versuchung
total schief läuft zu sagen es war einer
schuld das ist glaube ich in diesem fall
kann man das nicht so leicht sagen es
sind alle möglichen leute schuld gewesen
ich stelle nur fest in einem land das
ich hoffe dass ich jetzt niemanden
beleidigen und notorisch chaotisch gilt
und deren bewohner manchmal was
undiszipliniertes anhaftet in italien
sind die leute im moment sehr viel
disziplinierter als hier und damit auch
mit maßnahmen wo ich einfach sagen das
wäre wahrscheinlich in deutschland nicht
durchzusetzen fängt damit an dass wir
einen beauftragten haben für die
impfungen der us militär kommt ein
general ein gebirgsjäger der auch mit
vollem geklingel von orden da im
fernsehen auftritt und einer weißen
feder von den alpine und dann ist da ein
ministerpräsident der in die disco der
deutsche genannt wird völlig in völliger
verkennung wie hier die lage ist und der
einfach sagt das ziehe ich durch mit
denen es klare ansagen machen die reise
sei denn und ich war gerade in mailand
also da werden die sachen vom typ
verlangt wenn du ihn jemand besucht in
einer firma die werden hier
unvorstellbar insofern sagt es gibt
natürlich eine große verantwortung bei
der politik habe stelle auch fest dass
es viele bürger gibt die es nicht
einsehen und auch nicht machen wir sind
bei frank ulrich montgomery den wir
heute nicht hier an diesem tisch sondern
eben rostock begrüßen und zwar
ausgesprochen hat sich logischerweise
herr montgomery einmal auch ein blick
aus ihrer sicht auf die politik dieses
nie wieder einen locker und nie eine
impfpflicht das haben sie öffentlich
sehr kritisiert was glauben sie löst es
aus wenn man diesen vertrauensbruch im
bürger platziert hat darauf giovanni
garde ab
ja ich glaube dass das rica der politik
das wir erlebt haben in der letzten zeit
absolut schlecht war ich glaube einige
lorenz sie hat alles dazu gesagt man
konnte sich nicht einigen aus welchen
politischen gründen auch immer was mich
jetzt aber bewegt ist die hütte brennt
und ich mir jetzt völlig egal auf
welchem recht konstrukt jetzt dieser
werkzeugkasten zusammengebaut ist ich
will jetzt endlich loslegen und wir
müssen endlich was tun sei es durch
kontakt beschränkungen sei es durch
forcieren der impfung das wirkt ja immer
erst frühestens in sechs wochen sei es
durch brüste rung also wir müssen nach
vorne gucken am politik hat in meinen
augen in ihrem hick hack in ihren
streitereien die bürger alleine gelassen
und hat ziemlich versagt und da tu ich
gerne bewusst sowohl frau göring-eckardt
wihan brown dem ich ja sonst eigentlich
kollegiale rücksicht schulde aber in dem
fall muss ich sagen ihr habt von beiden
seiten aus komplett versagt das hätte
man alles wir haben als kassandra schon
vor sechs acht wochen ihnen das alles
vorher gesagt was sie heute erleben und
der schulden den bürgern jetzt den
respekt zu handeln und wir stellen
zwischendurch bevor wir wieder bei der
politik sind hendrix trägt natürlich
vorher strickt sie haben sind schon
zitiert worden es gibt
manchen streit unter den virologen und
man esse ich nicht hundertprozentig in
allen dingen einig aber man war sich
ziemlich einig unter den
wissenschaftlern dass da was auf uns
zurollen könnte und dass man darauf gut
vorbereitet sein müsste ja ich glaube
also ich weiß zumindest keinen experten
denn nicht gesagt hat der der herbst und
winter wird noch mal kritisch werden
auch mit den infektionszahlen aber ich
habe vor kurzem jetzt mir nochmal die
nrw stellungnahme die allerletzte
stellungnahme die der expertenrat
gemacht hat vor durchgelesen und war
ganz überrascht dass wir auch darüber
geredet haben das erwartungsmanagement
brauchen für die bürger dass man eben
sie darauf vorbereitet dass der herbst
und winter wieder kompliziert werden
würde das ja aber den sommer auch nutzen
dass wir krisenfester in einigen
bereichen werden vor allem im bereich
der pflege der krankenhäuser durch
planspiele zum beispiel versteht wie man
vielleicht auch mit kritischen
situationen in bestimmten bundesländern
um geht wohin verlegt werden müsste
vielleicht wenn die fallzahlen zu hoch
werden das haben wir leider nicht
gemacht was mir am meisten zielte über
den die sommermonate war eigentlich eine
nicht nur eine impf werbung das war
einfach zu wenig aber auch der richtige
immer auf klärung gesehen ja das
unheimlich viele bürger im moment noch
verunsichert sind ob sie sich impfen
lassen wollen oder sollen weil sie
einfach angst haben also ich glaube
schon dass man einen ganzen stück noch
erreichen kann auch durch gute
aufklärung das sehe ich zumindest an dem
e mails die jeden tag kriege es ist
immer mit delta begründet worden warum
wir jetzt zu überfallen sind und warum
es jetzt irgendwie plötzlich diese hohen
zahlen gibt eben mit dem vierfach so
infektiösen geschehen durch diese
mutation herr braun ist es nicht dennoch
so dass auch sie sagen müssen wo wir
eigentlich meine verantwortung was haben
wir in diesen zweieinhalb monaten
gemacht wo es eine wahlkampfzeit gab und
sich jeder bürger fragte er gibt es
eigentlich diese corona kabinette noch
worüber reden die womit befassen die
sich der spiegel recherchiert es gab
keines letzte mpk am 12 sie wissen dass
besser das ist ganz schön lange her also
würden auch sie sich sagen das hätten
wir besser machen müssen und nicht erst
in den letzten drei wochen warnen weil
der september und der oktober wurde
verschenkt also ich glaube nicht dass
man mir vorwerfen kann dass ich erst vor
drei wochen gewarnt habe das problem des
ganzen sommers war in einer phase wo
eigentlich alle das gefühl hatten das
leben das ist unbeschwerter die
infektionszahlen sind niedrig hat man
einen deutschen leitmedien in dem moment
wo man gesagt hat wir müssen jetzt
aufbauen für den winter wir müssen uns
jetzt um die auffrischungsimpfung
kümmert von horror prognosen von
titanic truppe
in dem moment wenn es nicht so brennt
wie jetzt dann beruhigen sich alle ein
stück und wollen und die akzeptanz
schwindet auch für die politischen
maßnahmen und ich habe auch schon im
august gesagt wir brauchen diese
leitwerte wir haben gewechselt von
neuinfektionen incidents auf
hospitalisierung was aus meiner sicht
gar nicht nötig war aber was was ein
symbol war gekippt wir wie wir reagieren
wirklich nur auf schwere fälle die ins
krankenhaus
diese eine impfwoche die offensichtlich
viel zu wenig wahrgenommen wurde diese
aktionswoche in die man sich heute noch
einwählen kann das weiß wohl niemand wir
haben am 6 september beschlossen dass
alle über 60 sich auf frisch impfen
lassen sollen und können die
gesundheitsminister hatten auch den
auftrag das habe ich nur gesagt in den
letzten wochen wenn man dann sieht dass
das nicht funktioniert da muss man so
schnell wie möglich mit bund und ländern
zusammen setzen und das ist jetzt noch
mal in dieser schwierigen phase vier
wochen gedauert hat bis wir dann mal
wieder alle am tisch bekommen haben das
ist wirklich das was mich massiv ärgert
weil das hat uns in dieser phase jetzt
wirklich in so eine elende situation
aufzurufen und zu ostern was wir jetzt
tun und jetzt sagen aber 26 millionen
und am besten in den nächsten fünf
wochen das hätte man ja auch so ein
bisschen früher starten können oder naja
das ist auch dass das muss man und ich
werde das jetzt mit den chefs der
staatskanzleien nächsten tagen ganz
intensiv angehen die hausärzte haben
über lange zeiten gesagt die auch mit
dem boostern das kriegen wir hin und
jetzt merken wir aber die zahlen das
sind jetzt vier millionen gewesen den
letzten zwei monaten es ist eben zu
langsam man kriegt viele schilderungen
von leuten die sagen ich bin weg
geschickt worden ich hatte noch nicht
die sechs monate ich habe meinen
impfterminen sechs brauchen so kann es
irgendwie ist ein enger brauchen
staatliche
impfstellen top das große zentren sind
oder dezentral ist mir völlig egal
aber wir müssen den größten teil dieses
angebots wieder über staatliche stellen
machen und das haben wir heute
vereinbart
ich mag ja nicht mehr über die
vergangenheit streiten aber das lka hat
ja schon sehr frühzeitig gesagt niemand
das machen muss mit dem intel hat die
haben schon sehr frühzeitig gesagt die
hausärzte werden nicht ausreichen ich
finde zwar gut dass sie jetzt nächste
woche da richtig loslegen und wir werden
sehr sehr viel brauchen und wir müssen
überall impfen wo es geht und es muss
jede und jeder machen können ich habe
mich ein bisschen gewundert dass in dem
papier der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
ist und nur wieder so eine kleine
bemerkung darüber steht es geht nicht
darum warum steht da nicht die in den
apotheken wird geimpft es würden bei den
haus bei den fachärzten geben dass
giovanni di lorenzo sagt oder her trägt
es gibt leute die haben sorge eine der
größten gruppen die sorge hat sind ja
nach wie vor junge frauen warum haben
wir nicht ganz frühzeitig gesagt lasst
uns bei den gynäkologen und gynäkologen
inseln bei dort ist es vertrauen da da
gehen die frauen noch alle hin und dann
kann man nicht nur sagen ebenso
aufklärung sondern auch gleich hier ist
die spritze wir machen das jetzt
zusammen also ich glaube es hätte schon
auch über den sommer sehr sehr viele
möglichkeiten gegeben und nicht zu sagen
die hausärzte haben gesagt wir machen
das schon und jetzt sind wir in diesem
dilemma wir müssen faktisch täglich eine
million menschen impfen damit es
funktioniert damit wir nicht so zu sagen
so eine dauerwelle kriegen die auch noch
über den januar und im februar hinaus
geht und diese aufgabe müssen wir uns
jetzt wirklich gemeinsam stellen und ich
höre jedenfalls dass es sehr viele gibt
die bereit sind aber dafür muss jetzt
richtig druck in den kessel damit es
auch passiert und dass es eben auch
dieses ganz entscheidende werkzeug wir
können ja ganz viel mit kontakt
beschränkungen was ja montgomery gesagt
hat und was weiß ich alles machen um
irgendwie jetzt einen stopp
reinzukriegen eine bremse zu ziehen da
bin ich auch wirklich zu sehr sehr
vielen bereit aber wenn das mit dem
impfen jetzt nicht richtig richtig
schnell los geht verlieren tag um tag
dann wird es uns auch im januar und
februar noch probleme machen das wäre
das kommt auf den intensivstationen herr
karan jahres ist ja da das wird auch den
intensivstationen eine noch
dramatischere situation leben als jetzt
schon hören wir herrn marko marin noch
mal dazu ja zu den zahlen ganz einfach
göring-eckardt hat völlig zu recht
gesagt wir müssten dann eine million
menschen pro tag impfen wir das noch vor
weihnachten hinkriegen wollen eine
millionen das war der absolute
spitzenwert den wir hatten als wir
bundesweit mehrere hundert impfzentren
aufgezogen hatten und wo ist die
logistik wo ist das konzept wo ist die
struktur wie will man auch den impfstoff
will man auch den impfstoff jetzt
verteilen der impfstoff ist ja nicht zu
kapelle die sie mit dem taxi in die
nächste fahrt zu schicken können sondern
sie müssen hier logistik logistikketten
aufbauen und deswegen sage ich mal wir
haben viel viel zeit vertan israel hat
bereits 95 prozent seiner bevölkerung
gepustet und wir reden noch einmal
darüber wie wir das machen wollen so wir
hatten vor riebsamen chef die erwähnte
dass auch in der letzten sendung hier
wie schnell israel 40 prozent der
bevölkerung musterte und mit welchem
effekt weil sie genau damit die welle
gebrochen haben was würden sie herr
montgomery sagen jetzt aus ihrer sicht
ist ist wichtiger die bisher noch
ungeimpft unbedingt zu impfen oder ist
dieses boostern jetzt von vorbei
da kann man keine vorrang ersetzen ich
bin glücklich über jeden den wir primär
also das erste mal impfen und wir müssen
auch boostern aber wir müssen ein
konzept haben wie man das macht sie
ersparnis hingegangen und hat gesagt
jetzt sollen die hausärzte alle impfen
dann brachen die telefonleitungen der
hausärzte zusammen weil natürlich alle
menschen die über 70 waren wollten
sofort eine impfung habe es auch richtig
also wie ich bedauere die
konzeptionslosigkeit obwohl seit dem
sommer eigentlich die ideen auf dem
tisch liegen was man machen muss
stattdessen hat man geredet hat sich
gezeigt hat sich getroffen aber hat
nichts entschieden herr braun können sie
uns helfen bei der beantwortung der
frage wie man das jetzt in welcher
infrastruktur möglichst super schnell
organisiert egal ob mit einem
gebirgsjäger an der spitze oder mit
jemandem sonst damit jemand im wahrsten
sinne des wortes krippen management
übernehmen und festlegen mit wenig
bürokratie schnelle erfolge also die die
kassen ärzte müssen jetzt sehr klar
sagen was trauen sie sich bis
weihnachten zu wenn jeder haus- und
facharzt 20 impfungen pro tag bis
weihnachten in seiner praxis macht dann
können wir fünf millionen schaffen und
das sagt dann dass darüber aus den
ganzen rest müssen den staatlichen
stellen machen und dann müssen halt die
länder die jetzt entsprechend aufbauen
wir werden diese in der nächsten woche
zweimal mit den chefs der
staatskanzleien darüber reden und wie
gesagt ich jetzt mal ernsthaft vier
wochen früher gewünscht und das wäre es
heute mpk landen ging einfach damit
zusammen dass erst dieses gesetz fertig
sein musste weil man vorher nicht wollte
dass die exekutive sich trifft und das
ist ein parlamentarischer vorgang der
muss ich jetzt auch nicht jedem erklären
weil man sich ja eigentlich fragt warum
haben wir nicht im september mit dem bus
land angefangen und da schon ganz
konsequent geworben aber das nur in
klammern wir sind bei christian karall
ghani dass er ist schon erwähnt und
quasi begrüßt worden lungenfacharzt
sprecher der intensivmediziner über den
ernst der lage muss man mit ihm nicht
diskutieren die versäumnisse in der
politik und jeder mangel und auch jede
und aufgeklärtheit der bürger landen am
ende bei ihnen einen guten abend herr
paradies wir haben
die frage wann sie und wie sie
eigentlich ihr team motivieren in einer
arbeit und für eine arbeit die
man hätte vermeiden können jeden tag 24
stunden am tag
ja also ganz vermeidbar sind glaube ich
intensiv fellow notfälle nie und wir
haben in den kliniken große routine
gewonnen das muss man glaube ich auch
mal dazu sagen und unsere mitarbeiterin
verhalten sich wirklich hoch
professionell in den letzten wochen es
in der debatte aufgekommen zwischen
geimpften und ungeimpften ein bisschen
unglücklich finde da ist ein bisschen
emotionaler druck rein gekommen den wir
auch die intensivstation im moment
überhaupt nicht gebrauchen können leute
konzentrieren sich wirklich voll darauf
dass sie jetzt die patientenversorgung
und die professionalität ist wirklich
hoch bei uns in deutschland es gibt
immer wieder das ist interessant wir
haben es angesprochen auch berichte
darüber
wie aggressiv menschen werden die
ungeimpft sind und eben gegebenenfalls
auch bei ihnen auf intensivstationen
landen und irgendwie auch ärzte und
pfleger angreifen haben sie so was bei
sich erlebt auf den stationen
ja das sind phänomene die beobachten wir
schon seit vielen jahren nicht mehr auf
der intensivstation sondern auch in den
notaufnahmen diese distanzlosigkeit hat
schon zugenommen auch insbesondere
gegenüber medizinerin ich glaube aber
dass wir insbesondere bei uns im westen
schon eher die situation haben dass wir
nicht überzeugt die impfgegner habe ich
habe keinen einzigen von denen gesehen
die bei uns liegen und mit denen wir
später gesprochen haben und das ist ein
ganz häufig menschen die 30 40 50 jahre
alt sind und gar nicht gedacht haben
dass es so schwer krank werden und sind
keine überzeugten impfgegner gewesen und
das ist auch das signal noch mal an die
politik wir haben noch eine gewisse
chance die leute zuerst im funk zu
bewegen weil am ende ist das neben dem
durchmachen der infektion die einzige
echte nachhaltige lösung alles andere
was wir machen verzögert ist wo und was
glauben sie von dem was heute
beschlossen worden ist jetzt das
wichtigste was würde am schnellsten
helfen zweig weil es den erwerb senkt
also zweig wird dem er wird
wahrscheinlich oben 0,2 vielleicht 03
punkte sinken aber der effekt wird nicht
akut sein dass boostern hat schon enorme
bedeutung das ist klar aber die ersten
effekte werden wir nach unseren modellen
frühestens in vier bis sechs wochen
sehen und ich erwarte und ich will dass
vielleicht auch mal so sagen jemand
comrie und herr braun ich erwarte dass
wir mindestens eine million erste
impfungen haben in den nächsten ein zwei
wochen das ist wirklich unabdingbare
voraussetzung aber auch das wird keinen
akku die effekt haben das was jetzt in
echten akku defekt hat damit wir die
infektionszahlen insbesondere in bayern
runter kriegen ist dass sich die
bevölkerung ganz diszipliniert an die
maßnahmen hält und dazu gehört
insbesondere das masten trage in den
innenräumen ja interessant gut dass sie
es noch mal sagen sie haben auch
natürlich diese letzten monate verfolgt
politisch verfolgt sie haben auch
politiker der fdp von frieden gehört und
anderes mehr es gab ja auch dieses auch
es gab ja auch dieses gefühl von
entwarnung und ich muss jetzt gestehen
wir haben auch bei ihnen einen satz aus
dem judo gefunden und ein ausführliches
interview wo sie gesagt haben sowie 19
wirkt langsam seinen schrecken verlieren
die menschen werden es nur noch als eine
grippe sehen es wird uns begleiten wie
eine grippe weil diese dritte corona
welle wird enden haben auch sie
diese hoffnung gehabt oder diese signal
ausgesetzt und es war einfach zu positiv
ja ich glaube wir haben im juni schon
versucht auch ein bisschen dahin zu
kommen die krankenhäuser darauf
vorzubereiten dass dieses virus
vielleicht wirklich irgendwann endemisch
wird das bedeutet dass es uns immer
begleiten wird und das wird uns in den
wintermonaten stark begleiten das wird
in den sommermonaten weg gehen aber es
wird auch in den nächsten jahren da sein
und unsere große hoffnung war vielleicht
noch im juni dass das vielleicht diese
saison schon der fall ist wir haben uns
aber sehr schnell korrigiert wir haben
im juli schon wieder die ersten modelle
vorgestellt ich glaube ich sehr präzise
vorausgesagt haben dass in einer großen
patientenzahl rechnen müssen und glaube
das haben die gebetsmühlenartig wirklich
fast jede woche gesagt dieses
schreckgespenst von der trial steht nun
heute wieder vor der tür das heißt es
muss eine auswahl der kranken geben nach
entsprechenden therapien wie realistisch
ist es und befürchten sie dass auch für
ihre einrichtung
nein ich bin auch kein wort des freund
des wortes trial stress bedeutet dass
ich aktiv das leben eines menschen
beendet zugunsten eines anderen mit dem
gesundheitssystem mit den ressourcen die
wir haben wäre das wirklich die
bankrotterklärung unseres staates das
ist ihm gar keinen fall in ihm war das
was wir aber breitflächig sehen werden
ist priorisierung ja wir haben bei uns
in der klinik den schwerpunkt der
künstlichen lunge sie haben einfach eine
begrenzte zahl von betten und sie haben
immer mehr anfragen aus anderen
krankenhäuser als sie bedienen können
das bedeutet sie müssen da auswahl
treffen und diese priorisierung die sie
in der regel nur in großen zentren haben
die wird bereich fläche
wochen und monaten und wir müssen
versuchen möglichst alle patienten
versorgen so versorgung und ich bin mir
auch sicher dass wir es schaffen können
ganz praktische frage wie funktioniert
dass patienten nun auch zu verteilen aus
besonders betroffenen regionen in
entspanntere weg kümmert sich darum wer
koordiniert ist
ja ich möchte hinrichs strich vielleicht
nur sagen wir haben unsere hausaufgaben
schule ein bisschen gemacht im sommer
und werden das auch vorher schon gemacht
wir haben uns natürlich gedanken gemacht
wo können die patienten hin es gibt
bunte änderungen dazu ich bin teil einer
fachgruppe am robert-koch-institut der
gruppe kaufen und wir sind für die
strategische patienten verlegung sind
wir beratend da wären ein kleeblatt
konzept in deutschland erarbeitet haben
auch simulationen durchgeführt was man
machen kann wie man die patienten
verlegen kann das ist sehr wohl
vorbereitet man muss aber immer bedenken
wenn sie in bayern stand heute fast 900
patienten haben und es kommen am tag
noch mal mindestens 40 in der summe dazu
dann wird das nicht reichen um die
patienten wirklich über die republik und
zu verteilen so dass bayern völlig
entlastet ist das bringt uns ein
bisschen zeit und das wird wichtig
werden in den nächsten zwei bis drei
wochen bis die maßnahmen greifen aber es
ist am ende nicht die lösung dass ein
bundesland wie bayern zum beispiel nicht
völlig ab sollte
christian carr adidas wir danken dass
wir mit ihnen darüber reden konnten und
ihre expertise hier in der runde hatten
vielen dank und natürlich weiter treu
und passen sie gut auf sich und ihre
mitarbeiter auf und auf die patienten
natürlich danke schön wir sind bei der
wichtigen frage frau göring-eckardt wie
wir jetzt eigentlich organisieren das
bis dahin bis wir eben im verfolger
haben 2g und 3g uns helfen weil menschen
dabei aussortiert werden also zwei geben
und in welcher konsequenz
er ist ja sozusagen die nächste
alarmstufe in der wir jetzt gerade sind
und 2g haben ja die länder heute auch
verabredet die ministerpräsidentin
ministerpräsidenten heißt ja in erster
linie in allen einrichtungen
freizeiteinrichtungen etc
man kommt halt ins café oder ins kino
nur noch wenn man entweder genesen oder
geimpft es punkt und dann gibt es auch
kein weiteres vertun und es ist
natürlich richtig dass wir das berühmte
zweig plus also irgendwie man das gefühl
man versteht nur noch bedingt aber das
heißt eben es könnte auch sein muss
zusätzlich getestet werden oder
eigentlich noch besser man trägt
trotzdem noch eine maske im innenraum
kann man im restaurant als ich machen
wenn man was ist also doch lieber
getestet im theater reicht die maske und
das müssen wir jetzt machen wenn wir
wollen dass diese
möglichkeiten noch weiterhin beide
bestehen viele haben ja hygiene konzepte
gemacht das ist auch übrigens der
unterschied zum november letzten jahres
von giovanni di lorenzo sprach gekonnt
wir konnten ja lernen aus den
erfahrungen wir sind ja nicht mehr bei
irgendwie nur noch die über 70-jährigen
gründen geimpft werden und wir haben
eine ganze menge von erfahrungen im
handel in der gastronomie in der
hotellerie vor allen dingen bei den
kulturinstitutionen wie man geschützt
irgendwohin kann und deswegen ins freie
gehen bei unserer leser ist ganz wichtig
am arbeitsplatz und das ist dass es
natürlich eine völlig andere situation
als wir sie heute haben also entweder
man ist im home office das wird auch für
den bundestag und wahrscheinlich auch
für die zeit und für das
bundeskanzleramt das was neues wieder
bedeuten dass viele menschen von zu
hause aus arbeiten und die die an die
arbeit müssen da gilt eben dann wiederum
3g also entweder gebe es gelesen oder
getestet und zwar sehr konsequent und
auch sehr kontrolliert und es gibt es
dem büro eben das ist ja die frage der
bann ist der tiger zahnlos wenn man
nicht kontrolliert wenn wir jetzt zwei
g2 g + 3g einführen und es ist nicht wie
in italien und in mailand dass man
naja auf mit italien war italien sind
bestätigt dass korrupte land aber in
dieser musik sowie die spanier wie die
vorlesen wollen oder noch viel weiter
aber
ich glaube das ist das entscheidende
stichwort ist die reden hier viel über
das boostern das ist auch richtig dass
der stadt findet aber dass die die
zauberformel ist um diese pandemien
griff zu kriegen ist möglichst viele
menschen zu impfen und da kommen wir in
den sind wir in den ländern um blog lebt
wie ein da sind wir den letzten wochen
und monaten nicht so richtig
weitergekommen und da ist die große
frage wie gewinnt man wieder vertrauen
es muss ja wahrscheinlich ein
ausbalancierter akt sein auf der einen
seite vertrauen erzeugen auf der anderen
seite auch eindruck dort wo menschen
andere gefährden und das zweite was ich
sehe ist es wird zu viel kontrolle
abgeladen auf menschen diese kontrolle
gar nicht ausüben können ehrlich ich hab
ich habe es in einer apotheke erlebt in
hamburg in hamburg er noch eine ganz
gute
spezialisierungsgrad des das neue
zauberwort jetzt die niedrigste die
niedrigste überhaupt aber in einer
apotheke stellten viertelstunde ein mann
mit leicht querulant ischen gesicht ich
habe auch keine große lust gehabt mit
dem zu streiten ohne maske in apotheke
und dann frage ich die apothekerin warum
sagen sie nicht sie haben ja eigentlich
hausrecht er sagt ich habe keine lust
mehr ich bin nicht die polizei und es
gibt gastwirte dieser sehr gewissenhaft
sind sehr genau hinschauen ja andere die
weniger sind ich habe im moment noch
nicht so richtig das gefühl dass da im
land die entschlossenheit da ist das was
vielleicht so ein politiker wie helmut
schmidt mit dieser scheiß pandemie zu
besiegen diesen willen spüre ich nicht
an die grosse hat ja den vorschlag
gemacht apropos hamburg dass die bürger
melden sollten wenn ihnen solche
vergehen nachlässigkeiten bei anderen
auffallen auch
große zweifel
wolltest du erwähnen herr montgomery sie
sind zitiert worden und waren
in einer anderen sendung eines einer
geschätzten kollegin und sprachen von
einer tyrannei der ungeimpften und sie
sagten das haben sie ganz bewusst gesagt
wird es uns den retten wenn wir menschen
ausgrenzen
nadi austritt die grenzen sich ja selber
aus weil sie sind ja nicht bereit die
grundsätzlichen solidarischen akt
auch für ihre mitmenschen zu tun und
wissen sie wenn wir jetzt darüber reden
wie wir die zum impfen kriegen haben wir
doch nur die möglichkeit zuckerbrot oder
peitsche und wir haben uns jetzt ein
halbes jahr mit zuckerbrot probiert und
es hat nicht funktioniert und deswegen
plädiere ich und da bin ich bei frau
göring-eckardt mit 2g 3g und so weiter
denen klar zu machen dass sie auch die
folgen ihrer unvernunft tragen müssen
und wenn es so ist wie er karas und eben
erzählt hat dass er viele patienten hat
die gar keine motivierten impfgegner
sind sondern nur vielleicht im versäume
dann kriegen wir die vielleicht ja damit
jedenfalls mit überzeugung und mit über
rede und haben wir sie in dieser
politischen kakophonie persönlich
erreicht und sie meinen es ist jetzt den
klub den spieß einfach umzudrehen und
die ungeimpften zu tyrannisieren die
empfinden ist natürlich so
wie ich würde ihn ist und gar nicht
tyrannisieren ich will sie nur das ist
doch keine tyrannei wenn ich jemanden
die folgen seines eigenen handelns in
verantwortung selber tragen lasse er hat
ja das angebot der braucht sich nur
impfen zu lassen übrigens dieselben
stoffe sind die sichersten die best
verträglichen impfstoffe die wir jemals
und vor allem auch in so kurzer zeit
entwickelt haben und deswegen muss man
schlicht da man die leute hat nach wie
vor wenig zu wenig erklärt also selber
sie selbst also ich von berufs wegen ist
für uns ja ein bisschen damit befassen
auch ich habe eher spät verstanden dass
dieser impfstoff sich praktisch nach
zwei tagen auflöst so wie bei james bond
die befehle wieder kam aus der zentrale
sich in zwei tagen so in luft auflösen
brösel das muss man wirklich auch
erklären es sind ja zwei nur zwei stoffe
einer erlaubt den zugang zu den zellen
der andere ist der stoff der dann wirkt
und deswegen ist es dann auch eigentlich
nicht logisch dass das die dna
irgendwie beeinflusst aber ich glaube es
ist ganz der loretto die haben doch
fragen sind aber wir haben fragen sind
an bord vom erklären mit wie vielen
journalisten mit wie viele ihrer
kollegen habe ich habe mir strikt haben
alle geredet um es klar zu machen
vielleicht haben wir alle aber auch noch
eine idee ist dass herr strikt auf ihrem
platz vor zwei wochen in dieser sendung
vor dr katzen scheint steigen die ist
hier mit einer schwerpunktpraxis in
berlin an sie und dieser geht eben
irgendwie auch nachts in den park der
zum kotti zu leuten die haben noch nicht
meine krankenversicherung und die gehen
auch nicht zu ihrem hausarzt weil sie
keinen haben sondern der bewegt sie sich
auf die menschen zu die eben sozial
schwach sind und wahrscheinlich auch
nicht auf die idee kommen es
erstrebenswert sind einen geregelten
leben nachzugehen also müssten wir ist
jetzt meine frage aktiver werden um auf
gruppen zuzugehen die wir bisher
überhaupt noch gar nicht in erwägung
gezogen haben davon bin ich wirklich
überzeugt dass das der aufwenden die
cosmos studie sich ja sehr genau damit
beschäftigt wer sich im moment nicht
impfen lassen will und da auch ein
bisschen eine trotzreaktion herausliest
ich bin davon überzeugt dass viele
menschen sich eigentlich impfen lassen
würden aber immer noch fragen im moment
haben ich sehe das wirklich an dutzenden
e-mails die jeden tag rein kommen von
jemandem der eine autoimmunerkrankung
gerade kontrolliert hat und jetzt angst
hat durch eine impfung dass das
schlimmer wird und
dass das sind wirklich patient arzt und
gespräche die geführt werden müssen die
auch länger geführt werden müssen das
ist nicht etwas was man kurz über eine e
mail abhandelt oder so und
wahrscheinlich auch nicht in der
talkshow ich habe aber auch den eindruck
dass das das grundprinzip der impfung
einfach mal erklärt werden muss man sagt
man ist es sicher ist es ist ein toller
impfstoff usw aber es wird ja gar nicht
erklärt was da eigentlich passiert viele
denken rna klingt wie dna dass das gibt
eine genetische veränderung leute denken
dass das ist ein ganz neuer impfstoff da
kommt irgendein hokuspokus in den arm
rein das muss doch erklärt werden also
solange er noch ein viel größeres
missverständnis dachten ja ganz viele
und übrigens auch politiker und
vielleicht auch manche superschlauen
dass wir mit dem impfstoff tatsächlich
erlöst werden und überhaupt nicht
präsent hatten dass er eben seine
wirksamkeit vor allen dingen bei den
älteren in einer bestimmten zeit
verlieren kann erst recht wenn er eben
auf ein schwaches oder älteres
immunsystem stößt so also man muss sie
ja erst verstehen dass dieser impfstoff
den einzelnen bürger sehr gut schützt
aber dass er im grunde uns alle also die
wir alle miteinander leben wollen eben
eine auffrischung braucht und nicht
durchgängig schützt
wann ist das schlaue erklärt worden wie
kann man das gut erklären das ist eine
verfallszeit eben genau dieses dieses
diese teamaufgabe des impfstoffes gibt
damit wir uns weiter treffen können ja
also die die die idee der
herdenimmunität haben wir ja schon
relativ früh sehen glück beerdigt und
dann haben wir im juni ja schon gesehen
erste berichtet das zu 60 der schutz vor
der infektion bei rund 60 prozent liegt
mittlerweile gibt es einige studien die
sagen rund 20 noch schutz vor der
infektion wenn man die karte studie zum
beispiel nimmt aber dieser diesen
übergang auch den geimpften klar zu
machen dass die pandemie für sie nicht
vorbei ist und wir trotzdem immer noch
teil dieser pandemie sondern auch die
infektion weitergeben da hätte ich mir
auch gefreut dass ich mich gefreut wenn
wir das kommunikativ auch vorbereitet
hätten über den sommer meine die grünen
die fdp haben ja beide vorgeschlagen
dass man ab animiere hat einen
krisenstab hat wo man sich auch intensiv
hinter den kulissen gar nicht vorne
irgendwie in den diskussionsrunden
sondern hinter den kulissen berät um
auch schaut wie man das am besten auf
kommunikativ übrigen auch die
hausaufgaben die ich gemacht habe das
war gar nicht in angriff auf die
intensivmediziner wie herr braun mit
israel ja tatsächlich von einem guten
beispiel irgendwie damit einem guten
beispiel bedacht die israelis boostern
und sie aberkennen jedem ab dem neunten
monats den impfausweis sie erklären die
leute zu ungeimpften wenn sie sich nicht
pusten lassen auch das könnte man
einfach übernehmen und sagen das ist
eine gute idee damit macht man die leute
vielleicht noch ein bisschen
aufmerksamer musste gar nicht viel reden
da legst du einfach fest es dann im
status abgelaufen ist und dann muss sich
jeder was haben wir gesagt wir sind
jetzt eine situation dass wir jetzt
erstmal die bringschuld haben den leuten
einen booster impfung anzubieten
und deshalb würde ich darüber jetzt im
augenblick nicht diskutieren aber wenn
wir so sein dann im frühjahr irgendwann
sehen dass es dass es wirklich so ist
dass die eine auffrischimpfung hatten
auch was die übertragung angeht einen
sehr guten schutz haben dass eine welle
dadurch so gut bekämpft werkes in israel
gesehen haben da muss man zeit verläuft
oder sowas vielleicht nachdenken
mit denen wir legen die genesen sind das
wird dann auch nach einem halben jahr
auf und das kann man natürlich auf das
impfen auch übertragen